um what is the timeline for you and j
stone [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] whenever that shit's done
because karma threes um
coming out august 14th 14th and then i
got
i got carmen three fourteen me and
styles p
doing beloved too we about to do that
again
bring it bring that back around that was
that was too fun south p had a very
underrated 2019
that's you know he put out a lot of
quality hip-hop last year that
that's my guy right there that's big bro
um
so that's so august 14th beloved two and
then a j
stone project yeah and i'm doing one
with mary mary jake doing an album a
whole mary j blige album yeah
wow got like maybe three or four records
right now what
talk about that chemistry because mary's
a legend so i mean obviously
i mean just to do one song with her
would be amazing insane but no that's
you know that's one of them like you're
such a fan of somebody or you didn't
grew up on somebody's music or you've
been just you know
tuned into them so long um
it's fire like you know what i'm saying
like it just put me in another zone
knowing who i'm working with
knowing the legacy she already got and
the fact that she even
got to bring bring out that uh that
reasonable doubt
oh the one on the one okay bad boy mary
when you hear that you're going she's
named she that's she on marry on some
[ __ ]